[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos
votre magazine consacré à l'actualité
économique du territoire
tout de suite le sommaire opensky
plaisir prend de plus en plus de formes
le centre commercial devrait être livré
au printemps en 2020 30 magasins un
cinéma nous sommes allés sur le chantier
pour faire le point sur l'avancée des
travaux
repenser la périphérie commerciale le
titre de l'étude sur la zone paris ouest
forum jd portes de cheuvreux entre
maurepas et coignières nous avons
décrypté les premiers résultats avec
grégory gary fier c'est le vice
président en charge de la stratégie
commerciale à saint quentin en yvelines
enfin retrouvez l'actualité économique
en bref dans les yvelines avec l'annoncé
d'un partenariat entre la région
ile-de-france et le groupe renault
puis le lancement de la seconde édition
de ce col à la boutique école à l'espace
saint quentin
lancé en janvier 2010 est le chantier du
centre commercial opensky de plaisir
arrive bientôt à son terme l'ouverture
est prévue au printemps 2020 un espace
qui comprendra une trentaine de
commerces et un cinéma tv 78 s'est rendu
sur place pour visiter le chantier
regardez c'est une question de mois
maintenant entre mars et avril 2020 le
centre commercial opensky de plaisir va
ouvrir ses portes
une trentaine d'enseignants sera
installé au sein de cette infrastructure
ici nous sommes dans la galerie
marchande dans cette ancienne belle
galerie qui sera couverte par une
toiture en dans une matière qu'on
appelle le tf qui est une matière qui
est à la fois protéger la pluie mais
permet la transparence
les premiers magasins sont en train
d'être livré aux preneurs c'est le cas
notamment de prat et marque la cellule
qui est tout au fond vert - et donc qui
travaillent mal et ce qui commence
maintenant c'est cette phase
d'aménagement pour les différents
magasins l'aménagement intérieur
alors que le reste du chantier est en
train lui d'être naître complétée est
terminée des baies vitrées du marbre sur
les façades 200 personnes travaillent
actuellement sur le chantier et d'un
côté une zone commerciale fermé et de
l'autre une partie ouverte sur
l'extérieur juste derrière moi seul
couvre avant l'ouverture un escalier
monumental qui descendra jusqu'à la
partie ouverte la partie retail park du
projet avec en bas un petit miroir d'eau
autour duquel s'articulera une zone de
restauration on voit la structure
métallique est en train d'être montés
sur laquelle va venir se positionner ce
qu'on appelle la vêture du bâtiment
c'est à dire son enveloppe extérieure ce
qui sera vraiment vu par les
utilisateurs qui arrivent par la route
là vous êtes en train de faire le trajet
qu effectuera un véhicule en arrivant
sur ce site en empruntant les allées
pour aller vers les parkings souterrains
open sky va renforcer le dynamisme de la
zone commerciale plaisir les clayes sous
bois
à la clé plus de 300 emplois vont être
créés autre zone commerciale de saint
quentin en yvelines celle de maurepas
coignières l'objet d'une étude intitulée
repenser la périphérie commerciale
lancée en juin 2019 par l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
ce pôle commercial englobe paris ouest
le forum libé et les portes de chevreuse
cette zone regroupe de nombreux magasins
touche près de 270 mille personnes un
chiffre d'affaires estimé à 500 millions
d'euros
nous avons rencontré grégory galère
risquiez pardon grégory gary astier ps
vice président en charge de la stratégie
commerciale de saint quentin en yvelines
nous nous retrouvons à paris ouest la
première zone concernée par l'étude de
repenser la périphérie commerciale avec
grégory est restée bonjour bonjour vous
êtes vice président en charge de la
stratégie commerciale à saint quentin en
yvelines
vous avez lancé une étude en juin 2019
pour repenser construire cette stratégie
commerciale sur la zone paris ouest
forum jb portes de chevreuse objectifs
ses co construire cette stratégie
commerciale avec les acteurs économiques
et les clients globalement qu est ce qui
ressort de cette étude
alors cette étude qui a été menée entre
mai et juin on a eu à peu près de 1700
réponse ce qui n'est pas rien c'est même
beaucoup une enquête en ligne et on
s'aperçoit finalement que le constat que
font les clients les consommateurs les
habitants c'est le constat que nous
faisons déjà depuis longtemps c'est
qu'on est une zone commerciale alors
j'allais dire plutôt un pôle commercial
ce qu'il englobe que vous l'avez dit
paris ouest le forum de jbeil les portes
de chevreuse
on a voilà un taux de vacance qui est
aux alentours de 5%
on a une problématique en termes aussi
de
de mobilité sur l'offre commerciale on
n'a pas un positionnement clair et on a
aussi des attentes des consommateurs sur
une volonté de mieux manger d'avoir plus
d'activités de mieux circuler au sein
même de ce pôle de trouver une cohérence
globale et de retravailler aussi
l'urbanisme qui est vieillissant
c'est les trois thématiques qui ressort
de cette étude l'offre commerciale le
lien social au sein de ce pôle
commercial et enfin la mobilité on va
commencer par l'offre commerciale très
diversifiée on retrouve beaucoup de
commerces dans différents secteurs
d'activité c'est vrai alors au fil du
temps la zone commerciale le pôle
commercial s'est construit et sans
vraiment de stratégie ce qui veut dire
que coignières a un peu pris le
leadership sur l'équipement de la maison
avec les grandes enseignes que l'on
connaît conforama questo est mort passé
plutôt l'équipement de la personne avec
une locomotive alimentaire qui est le
champ évidemment le pôle historique
le pauliste aux rites et contrairement à
ce qu'on croit et c'est a plutôt un pôle
qui sert des intérêts de proximité est
aujourd'hui en effet on a une offre qui
n'est pas forcément cohérente voilà on a
des des boutiques qui se ressemblent un
peu partout sur l'ensemble du pôle et
donc il ya besoin aussi de retravailler
une identité claire un positionnement
stratégique claire pour l'avenir comme
le font les autres pôles notamment sur
montigny ou aussi sur son plaisir même
si aussi un travail à faire de ce côté
là en effet c'est une volonté des
consommateurs eux aussi d'une volonté
des élus de retravailler cette identité
qui n'existent pas forcément encore
aujourd'hui ou qui n'est pas très clair
et défini on pourrait imaginer un pôle
maison déco plutôt sur les portes de
chevreuse et le forum jb et puis ici le
service à la personne et plus les biens
de consommation pour les personnes ici à
paris ouest voire même d'aller plus loin
moi même d'aller plus loin c'est les
éléments sur lesquels nous travaillons
actuellement parce qu on est encore dans
la phase de diagnostic
vous savez on travaille avec les acteurs
économiques ont travaillé que la
population il ya encore d'autres
réunions qui vont venir de travail
on travaille aussi avec les services de
l'état on n'en est pas encore aux
scénarii opérationnel évidemment ça
arrivera l'année prochaine
et aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver ce qu'on appelle les 20%
différenciant qu'est ce qui nous
différencie
à l'avenir sur lequel nous devons
travailler sur ce pôle commercial paris
ouest les portes de chevreuse et le
forum du gibet par rapport aux autres
pots qui existent sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines et ailleurs
donc il faut qu'on a on travaille sur
ces 20 % et donc l'étude dont vous
parliez et va nous aider on a pas mal
d'idées mais après il a fallu mettre en
avant et ça pas de simples pour conclure
sur l'offre commerciale
un dernier mot sur une demande qui
revient beaucoup c'est le circuit court
l'importance du commerce de proximité et
aussi du de la consommation bio oui
c'est un positionnement sur lequel nous
travaillons on y est très attentif avec
le maire de coignières didier fischer
avec qui on est vraiment en phase
injustement sur la stratégie que nous
allons mener dans l'avenir et je pense
qu'en effet le manger sain bio
l'agriculture urbaine on ad on a de la
chance on a des agricultures sur le
territoire on a des fermes qui sont pas
loin on a déjà des anciens qui sont
installés sur ce type d'activité donc il
faut qu'on arrive à travailler aussi
pourquoi pas ne les regrouper à trouver
une thématique forte à les porter et je
rappelle également que on est sur un
pôle commercial mais qui est aussi
industriel il faut pas qu'on les oublie
on a une zone d'activité qui est double
visage et donc c'est toute la
particularité c'est d'arriver à mêler
les intérêts qui sont parfois divergents
tout en trouvant une dynamique pour
porter ces acteurs économiques pour
qu'on aille tous dans le même sens et
j'allais dire pourquoi pas aussi
travaillé sur cet aspect industrie
manger mieux qu'il faut qu'on travaille
dans l'avenir autre thématique rigoriste
et c'est le lien social et la vie mise à
part l'activité économique il ya aussi
de la vie au sein de ce pôle commercial
des habitations des espaces verts qui
sont en cours de développement
actuellement oui on a un écoquartier qui
est en cours de construction vous le
savez avec à terme plus de 1000
logements qui vont arriver
en plus du logement ce seront des
espaces de vie ce sera un cabinet
médical
une nouvelle crèche des espaces publics
des parcs des jardins partagés ou est là
il y aura une vie et le fait d'avoir
intégré également du logement de la zone
d'activités paris-ouest nous a permis
d'être retenu par l'état dans le cadre
de l'appel à la refonte de la périphérie
commerciale et donc ça permet aussi de
lutter contre les villes dortoirs de
retrouver de la vie du lien donc en
effet c'est un élément important est de
trouver du liant maintenant avec ses
constructions de logements avec la zone
qui va être réaménagé un dernier mot
c'est la mobilité c'est la dernière
thématique qui ressort de cette étude
portant la mobilité déjà pour venir sur
ce pôle commercial
le point fort ce qui ressort c'est le
stationnement les personnes les clients
arrivent à se stationner facilement
il ya énormément de parking éparpillés
sur la zone mais le problème c'est pour
circuler entre les trois pôles à paris
ouest forum jb portes de chevreuse
quelles solutions peut imaginer alors
déjà sur le constat vous avez raison de
le faire on a beaucoup de stationnement
parce que chaque projet était pensée
sans forcément de cohérence et on n'a
pas de lien entre les villes de maurepas
et coignières notamment sur les zones
d'activité le pôle le pôle commercial et
industriel
il faut qu'on arrive à retrouver ce lien
au travers des nouvelles mobilités donc
en effet on n'arrivera pas à lutter
contre le tout voiture parce que
évidemment les activités les produits
qui sont vendus demande d'avoir un
véhicule malgré tout on va pas quand
vous allez dans chez conforama chez
castorama ou acheter du gros volumes
vous n'allez pas prendre les transports
en commun malgré tout il faut arriver à
trouver aussi ces mobilités douces donc
l'axé vélo retrouver de la cohérence sur
les pistes cyclables
il ya aussi le carrefour de mails me
donne qui va subir des lourds travaux
entre 2023 et 2025 avec le décaissement
ce terrain de la nationale 10 donc
directement l'accès à la gare depuis la
départementale donc tout ça va
fluidifier
il faut qu'on arrive à retrouver aussi
dans l'urbanisme commercial qu'on va
rien inventer les aménagements futurs ce
lien entre la voiture les mobilités
douces peut-être même les transports
autonome net innovant de travail et les
entreprises également de sur leurs
besoins et le transport en commun avec
l'agglomération
voilà pour on a été déjà un peu plus
loin qu'auparavant avec l'agglomération
ces dernières années puisque on a
davantage de lignes de bus ou de
fréquence de bus qui passent dans la
zone d'activités il faut qu'on aille
beaucoup plus loin
donc c'est un travail de fond qui va
demander aussi de l'argent public mais
si on souhaite également concilier c'est
à dire l'accès et la dynamique du pôle
commercial avec l'écologie il faut qu'on
travaille les mobilités douces
la véhicule de véhicules électriques on
le voit sur la zone d'activités on a
très peu de d'emplacements de bornes à
recharge large à exactement donc il faut
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin dans ce
secteur là donc c'est tous les enjeux
qui nous qui nous amène dans l'avenir
grégory galiffi merci beaucoup merci à
vous dise président en charge de la
stratégie commerciale à saint quentin en
yvelines
passons tout de suite à l'actualité
économique en bref dans les yvelines
le groupe renault et la région ile de
france ont annoncé un partenariat
vendredi 11 octobre au technocentre de
guyancourt
objectif développer un réseau de
navettes autonome entre roissy et la
défense à l'horizon 2024
la région va investir 100 millions
d'euros dans ce projet avec
l'utilisation des infrastructures
autoroutières à 86 et à 1
des tests vont être réalisés sur ces
sites une navette qui pourrait
s'inspirer du concept car easy go un
projet qui va contribuer au dynamisme de
l'activité du technocentre
comme l'a rappelé madame la présidente
on a beaucoup de deux intelligences
artificielles entre guillemets ici donc
on a des 100 décès de simulation c'est
vraiment le lieu on peut marier les
différentes expertises nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire aboutir ces concepts on
est aussi dans une marque de confiance
très forte de la région vis-à-vis de son
industrie automobile qui va développer
et j'en suis sûr dans les années qui
viennent la mobilité du futur
la boutique écoles scola ouvert ses
portes le 2 octobre à l'espace saint
quentin jusqu'au 22 novembre vingt
jeunes âgés de 18 à 30 ans vont
bénéficier d'une formation au métier de
vendeur des cours théoriques des
rencontres avec des professionnels mais
aussi des conseils dans la confiance en
soi leur expérience se conclura par un
stage de deux semaines dans un magasin
ce numéro merci de nous avoir suivis et
mission à revoir en replay sur notre
site internet ou sur l'application
mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]